- Hi, my name is Levi Kring.
and we're at my shop
Hick Forge.
Built it all by hand.
Let me show you around.
So this is my Shopsmith.
I got it
from my wife's grandfather.
It was his pride and joy,
and now it's my pride and joy.
So this is the motor.
It has a bunch
of different attachments to it.
The way it's set up right now,
it's set up for a lathe,
and if you slide the motor
on this side,
it connects to the band saw.
It's got other attachments
for a table saw
for a miter,
for a horizontal drill press.
It's pretty much a multi-tool,
all-in-one kind of a deal.
- Hey, I'm Ashe Cravenock,
and this is my home forge.
It's my propane forge.
It's what
I've been using lately
for just making smaller knives,
hunters,
and every day carry stuff.
This right here is
my first charcoal forge.
Me and my dad built that
when I was about ten years old,
and that's what I learned
to forge in.
I recently built
this sword forge.
Charcoal once again.
I got some orders
for some swords
and have no way
of heat treating them.
- I run a coal forge.
I don't use propane
or anything like that.
I like coal
because you can pretty much
do anything you need to in it.
My forge is ran off
a hair-dryer for now
until I get a bellows built.
And so it pumps air
in underneath here
into the air chamber,
and air just blows up top here.
And then it just heats up
the coal and simple.
Just keep the fire going.
Here's my grinder.
I built this.
Got some plans
off the internet.
The wheels are
skateboard wheels.
It's running off of
a five-horsepower motor
which is way over kill,
but it's what I had.
So it works good.
That's pretty much it
for the tour of my shop,
and, uh, thank you
for watching.
And welcome to Hick Forge.
- This is my anvil.
It was given to me
by a old blacksmith
in Truth or Consequences,
the town near here.
I've tied sisal
and leather
around some parts of it
to kind of dampen
the noise a little bit
'cause it gets loud in here
and I don't like
having to wear big earphones
in the summer.
It gets hot.
This is my belt grinder.
I just recently
got it actually.
It's my first piece
of real equipment,
and, man, it's a game changer.
I was using files,
and, like, this little thing
that sometimes spun around.
So now I can actually move
some material.
Thanks for visiting the forge,
and it's time for me
to get back to work.
See you guys all later.